[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avis au curieux et aux féru d'histoire
le château de maison à Maisons-Laffitte
vous propose des visites guidées des
petits appartements du haut de la
coupole grâce à un petit escalier dérobé
découvrez des espaces normalement fermés
à la visite on se trouve effectivement
dans un des une des petits un des petits
appartements de du château de maison ces
petits appartements servaient de pièces
à vivre pour des invités de rangs
moindres par rapport au roi où les
enfants du propriétaire et donc ici on a
cueillait soit des membres de la
noblesse soit éventuellement des savants
des philosophes et au début du XVIIIe
siècle c'est ici que Voltaire sera
accueilli par son ami Jean-René de
Longueuil qui était propriétaire du
château un séjour durant lequel Voltaire
a failli mourir par deux fois au
anecdote c'est aussi dans ses petits
appartements que Mansart l'architecte du
château à ses journées ainsi que le
général Lafayette est député de la scène
c'est un homme politique et un banquier
et il va être à l'origine d'un d'un
complot qui vise à chasser du pouvoir
Charles X le petit frère de Louis XVI
qui est droit à ce moment-là et qui
s'est insurrection en fait va être lié
aux trois glorieux ces trois journées
qui vont pousser le roi à quitter le
pouvoir tout ça ce fomente ici et parmi
les mystères du château cette pièce
accessible uniquement par une trappe
située sous une cheminée personne ne
sait encore aujourd'hui à quoi elle
pouvait servir la visite des petits
appartements du château de maisons se
déroule tous les dimanches à 14h jusqu'à
la fin du mois d'octobre la réservation
est limitée à 10 personnes maximum en
raison des espaces assez réduits